[Soft piano music]
[Porter] I study proteins and proteins have been
thought to have one structure that has one function or fold.
I'm studying this
group of proteins called fold switching proteins.
So, they can actually change
their structures and their functions in
response to changes in the cell. So you
can kind of imagine fold switching
proteins are like a transformer where in
one case the protein is like a robot
that does one thing and then in another
case, in response to changes in our
bodies, it becomes a car and can do
something else.
And an advantage to this is it can
respond really quickly to changes in our bodies.
Back in high school, I did not
imagine myself being a scientist at all.
Before going to college, I did kind of
fall in love with math like when I took
calculus. I was like wow this is so cool!
It was like the first time I realized
that math could be useful for something
beyond balancing my checkbook.
At the end of my sophomore year of college my dad
was diagnosed with stage 4 Lymphoma.
He went through multiple rounds of chemo
and it was just a really hard process
just watching that happen and and like
thinking I wonder if there's a better way.
Some of the proteins that I'm
working on that actually do this
phenomenon called fold switching are
actually associated with diseases so
cancer, Alzheimer's, autoimmune disease
bacterial and viral infections.
If by the end of my life even
one successful treatment was made based on this that would be amazing.
NLM has a really strong track record in computation.
There are a lot of excellent
scientists here and so I thought it
would be great to be able to work with
them. I'm also like really grateful to
have the freedom to pursue what I want
to do and I'm really like happy to be
here and be able to like take chances
that I probably couldn't do in most
other environments.